Hello and welcome to Holotalk, the Internet Radio Broadcast for lasers and holography, enjoyed by listeners throughout the world.
I'm Frank Defratis, and I'll be your host for each installment, bringing you news, guests, and everything holographic.
Now, please enjoy the latest show.
Hello, is this Dr.
Mitchell?
Yes.
This is Frank Defratis with the Holotalk Show.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
How are you?
I'm fine, thank you.
Uh first off, uh perhaps you could tell the listeners a little bit about your background specifically with this uh quantum hologram and your research with ESP.
I mean, we're all aware of your uh your Apollo uh history.
And uh maybe you could let the listeners know a little bit about how you got involved with this quantum holography theory and uh also about your experiments with ESP from most of the things that we read.
Uh it says that uh a lot of these uh discoveries and and thoughts of yours occurred on your trip back from the moon, but actually this was a lifelong interest of yours, wasn't it?
Yes.
How long have you been involved with the theories behind quantum holography or the quantum hologram and your research in ESP?
Twelve years.
Yeah.
And you've uh you started this in in what way?
What led you to what led me to it was I will uh I was delivering a lecture at Cambridge University in nineteen um ninety five, I believe.
Okay.
Nineteen ninety fineteen ninety five.
Um summer of nineteen ninety five on uh uh uh uh a model of thinking that I was using concerned with my research in the nature of consciousness.
Okay.
And uh after that lecture in which I had suggested that information was vitally important as we trying to understand the nature of consciousness because consciousness means that we're aware and information is how we know anything.
So um I was gave a lecture on this, and after that lecture a uh person in the audience came up to me and said, I think we've uh uh recently discovered something that puts meat on the bones of what you're talking about and actually validates it, and so I said, Well let's go hear about it.
And that was Dr.
Peter Marsher, who is now retired from CERN laboratory of CERN uh in Switzerland.
And he told me about the uh Walter Schimp's work in the quantum hologram and they were applying it mostly to quantum information and to and Schimp was working on MRI theory, how to improve the MRI and he had discovered what he had then called the quantum hologram.
And I listened to what he had to say and realized that was vital to the study of consciousness, to how we perceive, uh how we're aware and all, that it was a very vital uh block.
What did he say about the quantum hologram?
Well, uh, first of all, the quantum hologram is a non-local informational structure, which means it's quantum.
And first and furthermore, it demonstrates because it is rooted in the emission absorption phenomenon of all physical objects that emit and reabsorb energy, even down to the to the level of uh zero degrees Kelvin uh and is non-local, then that clearly is a quantum phenomenon.
And he had analyzed it with uh using the conventional uh Dirac Heisenberg nil potent Lee group algebra.
And uh that was his mathematical approach to it.
And uh it was been now validated several several times over in my work and in my colleagues' work, that this is really at the basis of of how we perceive information at all, that at the very bottom of our perceptual mechanism, uh it's tuned to this this type of information, quantum information, and we have established that over and over again in uh experiments in the laboratory to demonstrate that uh you cannot shield uh this type of information, that you can put vertical cages and all sorts of shielding around it, and people communicate through that barrier, and that's been well demonstrated in hundreds of experiments, if not thousands by this time.
Uh therefore, like gravitation, we're dealing with a fundamental quantum phenomenon.
Essenti essentially what you're saying is it's possible to transverse the space between point A and B without actually traveling the distance.
Exactly.
Well certainly information does.
And that would suggest that uh that is what Einstein called spooky action as a distance.
And that would suggest that since matter is energy also and information is patterns in energy that uh maybe at some point beam me up Scotty is is a a real possibility.
Absolutely.
And certainly transp transp teleporting uh particles has already been done.
So the real the real question there is what scale size are we talking about?
And the real problem with all this has been that for 75 years the physicists have not believed that this these quantum processes really applied to our scale size that uh they were that was only a subatomic phenomenon and the fact that by applying this formulation of this mathematical formalism to uh macro scale objects of virtually all objects and finding that it still holds that the information is emanated by all objects and let me be specific here what Schimp discovered is that the emanations from any physical body when considered as a group and let me use a metaphor to get this point across or analogy.
If you look at the little swirl on the tip of your finger, it doesn't tell you much about you.
But if you look at the s pattern of swirls on all ten fingers, that's your fingerprint, and it uniquely identifies you.
Well, the emissions from any physical object, when analyzed in the way SIMP has done so, carries information about that physical object.
And you have you look at it with regard to the berry phase, which is in the literature and a proper approach here.
Um the physical condition by which the information is uh transferred is called phase conjugate adaptive resonance, and so mathematicians will understand that as well.
Is that really as we that it's uh the concept of an anti-wave or a negative wave, and let me give a specific example here.
If you snap your finger, and you hear the snap, it appears to be at the location of the finger, where the snap is, not in the brain.
So how does the brain, how does the brain interpret that the snap is at some distant location as opposed to being in the brain itself.
It's exactly the same way bats and dolphins uh and radar uh create the uh location of an image or a target.
It's phase information.
It's phase information, just phase conjugate information.
It establishes essentially uh a pseudo-wave or a cyber wave or uh uh uh virtual wave that is the equivalent of a standing wave between itself and the object.
Now that's a modeling technique, of course, but that is the way it the distance is determined so that it can locate the target.
Well, that is exactly how the quantum holographic information is uh the relationship of the of the matter, the wave and its emitting object, or if you're to perceive it, the sort of way that uh you must uh uh resonate with the emitting object in order to get the information.
So it's a well-established principle, and we have now tested it uh in a whole host of um uh circumstances and found it is valid.
As a matter of fact, a colleague of my foundation, uh Dean Raiden, um, and doing this sort of research has recently written a book called Entangled Minds, uh, in which he is uh discussing precisely this type of phenomenon.
And uh all of the experiments that we have done, including that this type of phenomenon virtually answers all of the passive aspects of the uh so-called ESP phenomena, or all of the so-called I I I dislike this word, all paranormal phenomena, it's not para at all, it's very normal.
Yes, it's exactly the way things work at that level of reality.
I've always been a strong believer in thought being a part of this process as well.
It exactly is, yes.
Now, certainly thought is um thought can be transferred, transferred, transmitted and communicated in uh verbally and in a by emotions and a few other ways.
But nevertheless, it is a part of the same concept, the whole oh let me let me say it in the following way.
We have traditionally called our intuition our sixth sense that's that's what's in the lore that's a c cultural lore we call intuition our sixth sense but it's clearly a quantum uh information structure and it should be called our first sense because it was around long before our planetary environment uh formed and our normal five sensory mechanisms are based upon the conditions of our planetary environment so and the the quantum information is more fundamental so that's why I say to get the point across is that intuition should really be called our first sense because it is tied in and a part of the process upon which all the other sensory uh informational mechanisms are structured.
What about the fact of thought being able to form and control the reality that we live in.
Okay.
That's that's the um that's the a pat uh we've talked been talking about the passive aspect that is the active aspect of thought and that is the one that's a little tougher to model but all the principles that we're talking about here are important and valid there also now I have worked with all sorts of intentional thought processes and it's very clear that intention helps create reality.
I won't say it totally creates reality, but it certainly uh can modify our interact with the physical reality.
Now I have studied the healing mechanism, which is uh been discussed for millennia in the mystical and religious traditions, the healing mechanism, um, the uh processes of some very gifted people who really have this fine tuned, like uh some of the healers I've worked with, and Uri Geller in particular, the uh the Israeli psychic that I worked with for years ago, and is still quite powerful, and uh a healer in particular that I worked with that was able to do psychokinetic type of phenomena.
And all of us can do it to a l to a certain extent.
And the more we understand it, believe in it, and believe in ourselves, the more you're able to do it.
It's trainable if we break down our barriers.
So there's a number of things that work against us as well, not only genetically, but uh self-esteem and things of that nature as well.
Yeah, of course.
We're always trying to cut ourselves short sometimes, and uh our best intentions go down the tubes.
It seems that when we think we're going to have a good day and we truly believe that, we have a good day.
I mean, we think we're not, we don't.
That's right.
And our mindset, our belief system, our mindset is very fundamental to all of this, absolutely vitally important.
And uh circumstances, of course, can uh change things for us and we have to accommodate them.
My bottom line as I look at this and try to look at the big picture is the following is to say that we live in an intelligent, creative, learning, self-organizing, trial and error, participatory, interactive, non vocally interconnected, evolutionary system.
And that is our my description of the type of universe that we live in and are a part of because we're intimately a part of all it is.
And that's primarily what the holographic formalism shows us that everything in the universe is interconnected in some way and at some level.
What we're dealing with here is a universe that shows its energy in two forms.
It's energy as structure, we call matter, and energy as information, which is the basis of of consciousness, which is the basis of our knowing anything.
And the fundamental interaction in quantum particles of once they're interacting in a process, they remain quantum correlated.
If we uh call that, and this is a proposition, if we call that quantum correlation of particles the most fundamental aspect of awareness, then we're starting to build up this whole uh concept we know as consciousness, and that's the approach I've taken to it.
Now you have founded an organization, the Institute of Noetic Science.
Uh could you tell the listeners a little bit about that uh organization?
Because I believe you have chapters across the country, and when I was looking on their website, I noticed that there's one right here in Allentown, Pennsylvania.
Well, we certainly I started that uh organization thirty years ago, about thirty almost thirty five years ago now, uh, in early nineteen seventy three in early nineteen seventy-three in order to follow up on my insights from coming back in space uh to study the nature of consciousness from the point of view of science because that was not a subject uh science has looked at in the classical period at all however beginning in quantum mechanics in the early twentieth century uh the Cartesian notion that body, mind, physicality, spirituality belonged to two different realms of reality uh was simply nullified by the very existence that mind and matter do interact and in the quantum formulation.
But nobody has really uh pushed that or investigated that uh during the twentieth century until that's what I started to do in nineteen seventy three was to bring the tools of science to look at these type of phenomena including the parapsychology and the whole perceptual phenomena and the mystical experience and use the tools of science to say there is real science here.
And that's what Noetic Institute of Noetic Science has been all about is to pursue that course and over the last thirty five years uh yes we've been quite successful and we're in about thirty countries now with people are studying our methods and uh and doing their own investigations and uh we have well over four hundred study groups at USD one in Alentown also that um is involved with the piece type of studies.
What are some of the tools that are utilized to measure some of this phenomena?
Well, the basic perceptual tools, um, first of all, Faraday cages are were the very first most important part to show that this is a non-screenable phenomenon.
That in other words, it is a quantum, non-local phenomenon.
Uh and then uh the neurosciences have now gotten into it, and there's a lot of neuroscience being developed to understand, like Carl Carl Pribram, as you pointed out earlier.
Carl Pribbram was one of the early ones to say that the brain uh manages information in a holographic fashion, which is true, but then going further and showing exactly how it is working is where neuroscience is going at this point.
And uh so what we have been doing for for quite a number of years is uh replicating and validating uh many of these interfaces in the uh field and trying to pursue it, but more in particular to try to um help people move toward a more, let's say, a more enlightened spiritual aspect of in their thought structure to move toward a belief system that encompasses the notion that as a result of this phenomenon, there is a connection in the universe that the mystics have always talked about that's that the world uh and the universe is totally interconnected in some mysterious way.
And approaching that from the point of view of quantum mechanics has paid off.
It sounds very much like uh the new thought movement, which was at the turn of the century.
Yeah.
One of one of my most influential books has been by William Walker Atkinson, which is uh uh thought and uh the law of attraction.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And uh there's uh a series of books that were written, you know, back then that were actually part of the new thought movement.
Right.
Yeah.
And what this is doing is putting scientific meat on the bones of those ideas.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, which they didn't have available to them back then.
W they didn't have any of this scientific William James was very instrumental in this in the early part of the twentieth century in helping us to and rather in helping to get these ideas starting to move.
And now here late in the late in the twentieth century and down to the twenty first century, we have been able to use this mechanism, this quantum holographic mechanism, to show that there is a physical phenomenon involved here that is at a very basic uh fun fundamental level of how we perceive anything at all.
Yeah.
Well I had read one time that one of the reasons why we cannot detect the transformation of information from one individual to another with ESP is the fact that it's not traveling from one point in space to another to begin with.
That's right.
Yeah.
Now it and it's also it appears that in nature the quantum correlation is t tied up very much with the spin ki uh uh the spin uh characteristic of matter.
And uh it as far as we can tell at this point, there isn't any of our sensory mechanisms that are complete in and of themselves.
We have to have all of these sensory mechanisms.
And then we have to interpret the information coming in and give it meaning.
Well, giving meaning to information is just more information that you connect with your the base of your thought structure.
What is your worldview?
How does it fit in?
How does this information fit into your world view?
And you give it meaning based upon that.
And of course, since all of us have have different paths in life, like no two particles can precisely follow exactly the same path.
No two individuals live exactly the same way.
Uh we all have a slightly different thought structure and different world view.
And we give meaning to all the events in our lives dependent upon that.
And that's one of the reasons why we come out with so many opinions on the same exactly the same thing.
Including who's got the best God, which religions fight over for years.
Yeah.
You uh you have a DVD out precisely on this topic which is called Quantum Hologram.
If you could tell the listeners a little bit about that and I notice you have a whole series of DVDs and publications as well and we'll have a link going over to your webpage that the listeners can click on and go over there.
I actually have a copy of your quantum hologram coming in uh myself that should arrive either today or tomorrow.
Well you you're talking I don't know the uh there's a paper called Nature's mind the quantum hologram uh and then the DVD that you talk about is called uh the view from space the message of peace which uh uh describes the experience in space that brought led me to exactly uh what we're talking about here and both of those are available at your website to order from you.
That's right.
They're they're available on the on the uh website.
Okay.
And uh is there anything else that you'd like to add to all this and uh well I guess maybe for some of the listeners now we have a lot of school kids that are listening too, and I imagine this may be a little bit of a rough show for them to uh to get through, but perhaps if you could just this is sophisticated stuff.
It is very sophisticated, but it's so it's so basic as well, once you have an understanding.
It's something I've been following all my life and actually lived my life, and I believe that this is actually the basis of holography, of visual holography.
One of the things that we can say right here is that nature has been using holography uh in this sense a long, long time before we ever discovered it.
That's very that's a very good way of putting it.
Yeah.
Is there anything else you'd like to add to the conversation?
I would say also to the uh young people, the young the students that might tune in and listen to this, that uh I considered this work as important as going to the moon, and the important part is that uh it did give me the impetus and the uh uh start to work in this area, but it's all a part of the evolution of our society and our evolution of our social structure, and hopefully it will help us find ways to uh bring peace to this planet at the very beginning of the um space age.
The great thinker book minister fuller pointed out we're the crew of spaceship Earth and we're mutinous crew, and how can you run a spaceship with a mutinous crew?
And that's exactly where we still are these days.
Yeah.
That must have been some ride on that Saturn V.
Well, it was.
It was a great adventure, and what more can an explorer want uh these days, this day and age, than to visit some place that no humans have ever been, like the moon and another planet, and then to bring the story back.
And uh that's what we have done, and we're very fortunate to be a part of that crew of people that were able to do that.
That experiment that you conducted on the way back with folks back here on Earth that was to prove that their the distance didn't matter is that correct?
Well that was our intent and we did conduct the that D ESP experiment uh exactly in the same fashion that had been conducted in laboratories in the in the world, particularly in the United States, I followed Dr.
JB Ryan's work and we modeled our experiment uh around that and we got exactly the same results as he did.
Statistic very statistically significant results.
Mm-hmm.
That's wonderful.
Well I want to thank you for being on the show.
You bet.
What's nice about having internet radio is the fact that we can include links.
And since we've just even if we could say we even scratch the surface uh folks can have the links to uh go to this uh different resources that are available for them to get more information.
That's that's what's important.
Yes.
Thanks a lot.
Dr.
Mitchell thank you so much.
It's been an honor.
You bet.
Thank you so much.